hi my name is Beau Biden Attorney
General of the state of Delaware here to
talk to you about something that's very
important to me and to my office senior
abuse for every one of these types of
crimes it's reported to our office five
go unreported but two million senior
Americans are affected every year
in 80 percent 80 percent of these crimes
are committed by family members against
their so-called loved one we need your
help seniors need your help so if you
suspect that anyone is affected by any
of these crimes please contact our elder
abuse hotline at
1-800-223-9074 come on man
[Music]
oh we're having a little fun with you
this morning I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's February 23rd 2023. I
like the Symmetry there we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
share subscribe tap that notification
Bell if you have not and quick reminder
that tomorrow Friday we'll be live
streaming at a special time I don't know
exactly what time it is yet but we are
cutting the Blue Ribbon officially
opening the offices and Studios uh for
rumble in Sarasota Florida that's right
and I'm going to do the first ever live
stream from there I think it's going to
be around 9 or 9 30 a.m Eastern stay
tuned on that we're only going to be
live streaming that on Rumble and on
locals not on YouTube so subscribe if
you have not and uh yes that cold open
was a little to it is a little
gratuitous elderly abuse with Joe Biden
but we felt it was necessary because
yesterday Joe Biden leaving Ukraine well
he tripped up the stairs again
[Music]
it's interesting that he's always
tripping up the stairs you know what I
mean most people fall down the stairs
gravity would dictate that you'd usually
fall down but he falls up now there's
obviously something a little wrong with
his gate the way he walks I mean
something because of whatever's going on
is not quite right this keeps happening
okay I don't even mean to make a big
deal about that actually we're showing
you that because I'm mostly going to be
talking about Justin Trudeau today and
then we're getting to a locals Community
Q a but Justin Trudeau fell the other
day too and this one was just sort of
hilarious
I feel like we should have looped that
like 20. I'm just the tree no I fell on
that I Love You Gavin do some anyway I
really wanted to talk about Justin
Trudeau's policies today not just watch
him tripping through a uh a parking lot
over there uh let's talk a little bit
about Justin Trudeau and his feelings
about uh immigration in Canada and then
a bunch more let me talk to you guys
about Birch gold first and then we will
go from there uh you know despite the
U.S blowing through 31.4 trillion dollar
debt ceiling in January the leftist
White House still refuses to reduce
spending while our national leadership
has buried its head in the sand when it
comes to fiscal responsibility it's time
to pull yours out now would be a great
time to diversify into gold with Birch
gold in times of high uncertainty and
instability gold is King it's Dependable
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA and precious
metals here's what you need to do visit
birchgold.com Dave to claim your free
info kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists think
about it to dig our country out of this
mountain of debt every single taxpayer
in America would have to write a check
for about 250 Grand and it's only
getting worse protect yourself with gold
today visit birchgold.com Dave they've
got an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers countless five-star reviews
and you can go to birchgold.com Dave
today
get some gold all right let's talk about
Justin Trudeau he gave this big speech
the other day
kind of like a town hall thing and just
everything the guy says as I often say
about Justin Trudeau which is Loosely
quoted from my friend Jordan Peterson he
simply cannot say anything true even
when he says something that's like
pretty close to the truth it's couched
in a lot of Madness uh but here he is
explaining to Canadians why they need
Mass immigration now more than ever
there are a lot of pressures on our
system increasing the immigration levels
interestingly we'll take some of the
pressure off of the system because the
stream on bringing in permanent
residents is has got room to bring in
more and it's when people come as
refugees and try to flip or get Refugee
crisis the status that sort of slows
down the system a little bit so
increasing the levels will actually help
bring in more people to respond to that
it's also that he just says nothing the
Canadian system is not any under any
pressure sure that they need more people
in Canada now can Canada bring in more
people geographically certainly they can
I mean Canada is an absolutely massive
largely empty country there's not a lot
of can I get the number on Canadians how
many Canadians are there I'm going to
guess it's probably about 30 million
something like that yeah and they are
they're geographically absolutely huge
you don't need to look at a map to know
that like everyone should know that so
they've got room for people it's not
about room although a lot of people
don't want to live in an icy Tundra but
is what it is
um although plenty of uh you would think
migrants that are fleeing other places
would love to be there but for some
reason they don't go to Canada they all
come here okay fine
um this idea that the system needs these
people is crazy but Justin Trudeau is
not really the prime minister of Canada
I mean I get it that's what it says on
his desk but he really is an agent of
the world economic Forum he wants to
flood Canada with migrants with illegal
immigrants Canada has a policy of
immigration it's not as open as the
United States the United States you know
you take your poor your huddled masses
we take your fentanyl dealers we'll take
anybody basically and you can just walk
in and we'll give you a free phone they
are not a nation of immigrants in that
sense but the idea that they need them
it's like just be honest about it man
say hey you want to have more people
here because actually what you think is
you bring in more people you get them
locked into your Social Services you
think they'll vote for you and the
Liberals forever and you'll never have
to give up power just say it dude you
don't have to pretend that for some
reason the Canadian system which by the
way if the Canadian system is shaking in
any way it's because of you it's because
of your lockdowns it's because of your
attacks on Free Speech it's because of
everything you've done to the economy
and all that other stuff so
he need only look in a mirror but he
continued to say that Canada doesn't
have an immigrant problem because you
know they've got us right beneath them
and you know we're taking the brunt of
the storm people have confidence that we
have an immigration system that works
that there are rules to follow that
people come here and uh you know come
because they're qualified and because we
have two big oceans well three big
oceans on on all three sides of us and a
very attractive and warmer country
immediately to our South we haven't in
our history over the past many decades
had a lot of irregular migration which
causes people in the states and in
Europe to be a little more worried about
immigrants coming so this is interesting
stuff first off he's saying that they
have rules and it works that sounds an
awful like Donald Trump type right wing
stuff that you should have rules related
to immigration you should have a system
that works but what's the other issue
well they've got the United States
acting as the freaking buffer which is
incredibly interesting because you know
we get all of these people coming
through our Mexican border literally
about 2.5 million border crossings in
the last year more than ever coming in
bringing fentanyl crime all of the stuff
and even if they're nice people and even
if they have legitimate reasons to flee
their countries you still have to come
in Legally once you cross that border
you are now breaking the laws of the
United States I know we don't treat you
like that but that's how it is it's just
how it is and how it has to be if we're
to believe that a nation-state would
would be something that's worth having
and something worth continuing so it's
interesting that he sort of likes a more
Republican uh
policy when it comes to the Border but
at the same time he's telling you he
wants to let in as many people as
possible now it's very easy for him
because in essence what he's saying is
we protect the border right like we
protect the Border it's not as if he has
thousands and thousands of Americans
trying to get into the southern Canadian
border right uh the problem is that at
our Southern border we don't have a
border and all these people are
wandering their asses in to the country
uh Greg Abbott the governor of Texas
he's basically had it with Biden and
Texas is going to build its own wall on
top of all that Texas
is the only state in the history of the
United States of America that it has
ever built its own border wall
we have been in the process over the
past year of acquiring rights on land
owned by private landowners that will
allow us to accelerate the process of
building the border wall over this
coming year there's a possibility
depending upon how the construction
process works where by the end of this
calendar year
Texas is a state may have added more
border wall than the Trump
Administration did for the United States
of America during his four years in
office you really need to understand
this this is extraordinary stuff the
states are not supposed to worry about
the national borders they can always pay
a little more attention right if you're
a border state you got to pay a little
more attention say if you're Texas than
if you're just somewhere in the middle
of the country right like that's just
obvious because it's your land right
there but it's not their job it is one
of the few duties of the federal
government to make sure that our borders
as a nation are protected because Biden
and this Administration and mayorkas and
the rest of these people are are
completely not doing their job they're
either dropping the ball or this is
intentional I I at this point believe it
is intentional they want as many people
here as many people on the Dole as many
people voting illegally like I'm on
board all that stuff that that is just
my personal opinion come get me for it
but because this is happening uh Texas
is now saying enough is enough and we
are going to build a wall we are going
to pay private citizens so we can put a
wall on private property or they're
going to use eminent domain there's all
sorts of legal issues around all this
stuff but the point here is is something
that I've been trying to push for the
last few months which is that the
Republicans are not only getting balls
they are showing teeth
and balls that's
oh
the point is guys uh there is a new
attitude amongst conservatives at this
point which is we will not be messed
with relentlessly you cannot destroy the
known universe and watch us just sit
back and take it and that's a perfect
segue to one other thing that I wanted
to do before we get to the Q a because
you may remember over the last week or
so I've I've talked about this Andrea
Mitchell interview a couple times where
Andrea Mitchell from NBC News and MSNBC
she's been working there for a couple
decades she is thought of as a reputable
journalist she sat down with vice
president Kamala Harris and she said
basically
that Ron DeSantis wants to ban teaching
of slavery in the aftermath of slavery
in Florida it is a complete 100 percent
lie with no daylight no equivocation it
is a lie he took an one AP
African-American studies course as you
know out of the curriculum because they
were also going to teach gender queer
theory in that class so it was going to
teach critical race theory in essence
they were going to push for reparations
it was going to be an activist course
not an educational course so he took one
thing out Andrea Mitchell she knows she
either knows that or she's a complete
idiot I don't think she's a complete
idiot so that means that she's paid by
NBC to lie and her producers set up a
show to run cover for Democrats and lie
about Republicans anyway NBC has
subsequently been repeatedly trying to
get Ron DeSantis to come on their shows
they'd love to get Ron DeSantis on Meet
the Press or whatever MSNBC clown shows
there are and Brian Griffin who is the
press secretary for Ron DeSantis had an
absolutely spectacular response to them
yesterday he said to all of the Bookers
and producers reaching out to our office
from NBC and MSNBC for governor Ron
DeSantis to join your shows this will be
the standard response from our office
until Andrea Mitchell apologizes and
your track record improves here's the
actual response that he sent to NBC he
said I think we need to take a step back
there will be no consideration of
anything related to NBC Universal or its
Affiliates until and at least Andrea
Mitchell corrects the blatant lie she
made about the governor governor
DeSantis says that slavery and the
aftermath of slavery should not be
taught to Florida school children this
is false and NVC and its Affiliates
display a consistent track record of
truthful reporting please feel free to
pass this up and around the network
sincerely Brian Griffin now this is
really billion at two levels now first
actually I'll before I explain why here
just in case you don't remember the
original Andrea Mitchell clip this is a
little YouTube short that we made about
it this is Governor Ron DeSantis not
know a black about black history in the
black experience when he says that
slavery and the aftermath of slavery
should not be taught to Florida school
children it should not be some
politician
saying what should be taught in our
classrooms if you believed any of that
Kamala you would be for school choice
right it shouldn't be politicians who
tell kids what to do except you and the
Democrats are the ones that want all of
the kids going to public schools so that
they can be brainwashed by your teachers
unions and everything else Andrea
Mitchell what an insane what an insane
way of framing this what does Ron
DeSantis not know about the black
experience something to that effect what
a crazy way why does he not want slavery
and the aftermath of Slavery to be
taught it is a complete lie the segment
producer you have to be fired somebody
has to be fired but Andrea Mitchell
should be shamed everywhere she goes
because again either she's an idiot so
she's asking questions of which she
knows nothing about or she is paid they
are literally paying them to lie so that
Kamala Harris who's a can lie in
her response you think I'm clear about
my feelings on these things it's getting
very clear wouldn't you say uh Andrea
Mitchell that that really is the issue
but the she's either a liar well she's
either an idiot like let's just like the
best the most generous version is she's
just an idiot and she has no idea what
she's doing after Decades of doing this
and all her producers are idiots that's
like the generous like you're not
intentionally doing this version and and
clearly that's not the real version of
it right the real version is they are
paid to lie they want to make Democrats
look as good as possible and they want
to lie about DeSantis she knows of
course that slavery and the aftermath of
slavery have been and will continue to
be taught here in Florida that is one
specific course that he went after but
the response really is what I wanted to
talk about because the response is
brilliant on two fronts uh well there's
three fronts I would say first is just
the fight back just fight back okay
that's great the second front is now
you've exposed it you've exposed it so
Andrea Mitchell can either uh she can
either say boy I really screwed that one
up or they ignore in which case either
way you know what the answer is she's
guilty right and then on the other front
number three 3 on this one would be that
the rest of the media should report on
this right every day I show you freaking
Santa's Clips every day this guy is all
over uh every News Channel all the time
usually lying about him now NBC wants
him on air he is officially his campaign
is officially saying we will not work
with NBC News that's news in and of
itself
so you would think that ABC CBS CNN New
York Times Washington Post you'd think
they would write a story Governor Ron
DeSantis refuses to be interviewed by or
do any work with NBC news but they won't
write that story even though it would
hurt their competition you know why
because they're all in on it together so
it's a brilliant move by Brian Griffin
you're exposing Andrea Mitchell to be an
absolute fraud and at the same time
you're exposing the rest of the media as
people that are in cahoots with the
fraud
themselves okay let's get to a Reuben
report dot locals.com Community Q a free
us now 2020 says what do you think about
the Roseanne Barr comeback on Fox and
will you interview her so if I'm not
mistaken Roseanne Barr has a new comedy
special that they're releasing on Fox
Nation is that right so they're
releasing it on Fox Nation I saw one
little clip it was kind of funny it was
very very anti-woke uh complaining about
I think about her daughter or something
um you know Roseanne and I used to be
pretty good friends over the years we've
sort of lost touch these last few years
since I've I've left Los Angeles but she
was a brilliant comic back in the day
the original Roseanne show was
absolutely phenomenal her cancellation
you know they brought the Roseanne show
back it's number one it was the number
one comedy in America what like three
four years ago something like that she
makes one silly joke on Twitter
um who was the joke about it was about
um
no it wasn't the Ghostbusters chick no
no somebody that worked for the Obama
Administration Valerie Jarrett it was
about Valerie Jarrett and she said
something about her being a monkey or it
looks like a monkey or something
Roseanne I fully believe her on this she
didn't know she was black she was
certainly not making a racial joke the
whole point of the Roseanne show they
were fighting for working-class
Americans they had gay characters on
before it was cool to do that they had
some interracial people on television on
the program some of the friends that
they worked with at the factory or
whatever and she's just been on like the
front lines of fighting for the right
things over the years it's just so
profoundly stupid so they canceled the
show then the show of course no no well
they canceled the show first they fire
her then they bring the show back it's
not called Roseanne anymore now it's
called the Connors they kill Roseanne
and then of course that show tanks and
that's off the air too so they all get
what they want I hope she you know look
more voices the better she's a little
nutty but let's get her out there and
yes I'd be happy to interview her again
Giselle says what's your take on the
project Veritas O'Keefe kerfuffle love
that word and the timing of it seems
suspicious no have you ever interviewed
James O'Keefe I did interview James
O'Keefe probably about four years ago
you can go check that out he came in
studio we did that I think we aired that
one live actually if I'm not mistaken
um look project Veritas have they done
some slightly Shady things over the
years related to how they get
information it sounds like they probably
have but putting that aside relative to
what all of the mainstream media does
with everything might I point you to
MSNBC and Andrea Mitchell and NBC News
and all that
um it's not a big deal the only reason
project Veritas always has this light
shine on it is because they're they're
getting the other guys right they're
getting the Liberals they're getting the
Democrats they're getting the fauces
etc etc what they exposed over the last
couple weeks with that with that video
that we played a bit of where this uh
this young guy who's an executive
advisor basically admits they're doing
they're doing gain of function and it's
to put out more vaccines and everything
well then two weeks later suddenly James
O'Keefe is kicked off the company that
he founded it sounded like the board was
going to keep him then the board got rid
of him
all of that being said I don't it seems
to me there's something else going on
there and I just don't know what it is
they're saying they're kicking him off
because he had spent a lot of money on
like uber blacks and some plane rides
and things like that and that I guess he
had been abusive to some employees but
the timing seems weird and if it was
just about expenses for the most part
okay so he was rude to some employees so
be it
um but if it was mostly about expenses
those are things that can be reimbursed
so it feels like something else is there
I just don't know what it is uh Wayne
says when is your next visit to Texas we
don't have any Texas stuff on the books
do we
not that I know of at the moment uh I
would love to get back to Texas I like
Texas I I really like Dallas you know
that's where the blaze guys are uh we're
not working with the Blaze the way we
were before but we're still Distributing
the show over there uh and I'm sure I
could shoot a show or two over there and
go hang out with Glenn on the ranch or
whatever it might be uh so we will try
to uh to make something happen I'd like
to go to Austin just to see what's going
on with the Urban Decay over there I've
seen a bunch of videos and it's it's on
its way to San Francisco and la so I
don't know that I really want to see it
but I guess I got a friend in Austin so
you know maybe uh Benjamin says any
chance we can get a behind the scenes
episode or you accidentally leave the
camera on during lunch after the show it
would be fun to see what really goes on
in the studio well interestingly
usually now because the kids I go and
eat downstairs so that I can help David
with the kids Connor and Phoenix usually
eat in here so if we were to leave the
cameras on I assume it would be you guys
bad mouthing me you know that Reuben man
he blew it today it would be a lot of
that
um we've been thinking about some more
behind the scenes things you know we're
doing the post game show obviously for
locals now but we've been thinking about
some things out of the studio I'm
feeling a little constricted always in
this little box and we've got some ideas
for a live studio thing so we're putting
some things together stay tuned
supsi says what is your opinion about
our food supply and the many conspiracy
theories that are floating about I don't
know what to believe oh I mean this is
one where you see these factories
blowing up we've seen all these fires at
these food processing plants you know
there's what happened in East Palestine
like just these explosions and toxic
chemicals and fish dying and all these
weird things and it's like it's a little
bit of confirmation bias and that we're
seeing these things more because of
Twitter and online video and phones
maybe but does it also feel like
something really weird is going on at
the same time you've got the world
economic Forum people telling us we're
going to eat bugs while they you know
eat their A5 wagu it all feels very
weird I would say the best thing that
you can do is something we're trying to
do here which is grow a little food at
home if you can you know plant a little
garden grow some Tomatoes or some
lettuce you could consider the chicken
coop I would love to get a chicken coop
again we don't we had one in La for a
while don't have one now but like having
some we have we have an avocado tree
here a really mature avocado tree which
is awesome and we have a mango tree like
having some stuff
so that if the hits the fan like
you're able to survive like an extra day
or two although then everyone's like hey
that's not the guy with the avocado tree
and then you just get taken out another
way the point is I watch a lot of zombie
movies and uh you know just get a can of
beans and pray venae says peaceful
divorce has been suggested once again
this time by congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green do you think there's more
validity for it now
look I've I've mentioned it a couple
times I I don't like talking about it
because you know sometimes you can
almost talk something into existence
right so the more that a whole bunch of
us talk about this National divorce that
the red and blue are just going their
separate ways why should Florida and the
citizens of Florida have to pay the
debts of California which is so
mismanaged when we're doing it right
here you know that would be one example
of it what at some point what makes us
the United States if there are places
that are fully indoctrinating their kids
versus other states that are that are
teaching them an honest assessment of
History like what is uniting us at this
point we're so disconnected I mean I
feel this I really feel this like my
life as a Floridian and my day-to-day
operation and my family and my community
here and my co-workers and all that it's
so strong and and thriving and
flourishing here and that's in just
complete
contrast to what's going on at the
federal level all of the stuff that I
talk about on the show when it comes to
the president and farm policy and
monetary policy and all of the stuff so
like what is making us United at this
point I don't know exactly look the
problem the inherent problem no matter
what so we start a separatist movement
right from the prequels right and we're
like we just don't want to be part of
this bureaucratic nonsense you guys are
destroying the dollar the the you know
just everything is is out of whack
because you guys because half the
country doesn't know how to govern
themselves or is just doing it the wrong
way the problem is the blue States will
never stop like really if you took if
it's 10 years from now and everything
keeps separating the red States just
keep you know functioning as capitalist
States and care about freedom and care
about our founding documents and the
blue States just keep going the other
way and it's big government and taking
your guns and your sons or daughters and
all of that stuff well we can do that
for a while but at some point
the blue States will want what the red
states have because there will be they
will have all of the production all of
the good people who produce things and
Innovation and literally art and music
and everything else because freedom is
fertile ground for all the good stuff
that humanity is all about right and
they will never stop they will when
California wrote you know just goes off
the cliff
into debt it will want the Surplus that
Florida has and the federal government
will somehow try to facilitate that so I
don't know what we do but again you talk
about this and then you sort of talk it
into existence and it's like
I don't I certainly don't want a civil
war
we got to figure this thing out I don't
know what the answer on that one is uh
Florida man Chuck says what is something
about Florida that is better than you
expected I I I expected it to be great
it has been great
um the little bit that I've been out
about for the food scene has been good
but like right now with the kids we're
not getting out much and I'm just doing
a lot of cooking look The Secret of
Florida
I should probably whisper this Joe Biden
Style
secret of Florida
is that the Summers aren't that bad at
least down here in southeast Florida
Miami you know it's hot you don't want
to be out it's 95 let's say three
o'clock the sun beating down in the
middle of the day and it's humid the
hair is a little lower but there are uh
these things that you can put in your
window at your house or your condo and
they literally they are electronic
devices that you connect to the power
and they will condition the air
they are known as air conditioners and
and you get one of these things and and
you'll make it through the summer and
it's pretty sweet you might even go my
God the air is on too much
a little too chilly in here that could
happen it's just been great here it's
just been great I I have literally no
complaints I I just love it uh Richard
says since Vivek announced his bid for
president that makes three declared
Republicans so far sununu sounded like
he was going to get in the race on Brett
Bear the other night what do you think
of the number of candidates in the field
that'll be the Republicans when the
primary start I put the number at nine
well okay so let's say you got Trump you
got Nikki
you got Vivek
I think Pompeo is going to get in
let's say sununu gets in
so that's one two three four five let's
come up with a couple others let's say
maybe Tim Scott I'm not hearing any real
chatter on that but I feel like I feel
like it is a possibility who else who
else might get in on the Republican side
who else do you think I feel like
there's got to be like a couple more
you're saying nine oh well yeah I mean I
guess we have to go through the Larry
Hogan
he could count this too uh you know his
crew I I don't sense Tim Ted Cruz he's
going to get and John Bolton has said he
wants to get in a couple times no one's
going to vote for him but okay
um you know there's a Josh Hawley or Tom
Cotton I don't I don't sense they are so
what do I have here I have Trump Nikki
Vivek Pompeo so new new Tim Scott Larry
Hogan John Bolton that's one two three
four five six seven eight oh there's
this Rhonda Santos guy have you heard
about him I guess I should add him that
would put us at nine so your nine sounds
pretty solid to me actually they'll also
be like two surprises you know there's
always two like really out there ones
that get on the debate stage once
everyone laughs and then they go home so
we shall see uh Graham says Dave brand
new subscriber but I've been watching
your show for some time welcome aboard
uh one question I have uh do you do your
entire show with a black Sharpie felt oh
how do you do your entire show with a
black Sharpie felt marker in your hand
how do you keep from getting ink on your
fingers is that a superpower that you
possess uh you know the hands are
actually really pretty clean right now
something has happened in the last few
months where I'm always holding the pen
I'm Bob Dole Bob Dole holds a pen gotta
hold a pen
um I don't know I think it might have a
little something to do with I've been
I've been telling you guys I'm watching
a lot of uh old Johnny Carson stuff
sometimes he would be fiddling with the
pen like doing a little of this kind of
stuff I don't know maybe it's like it
almost like distracts my brain in a
little bit in some ways so that when I'm
talking to you I'm like totally focused
on that in a way so it's like it takes
out a certain
part of of the thought process or
something I don't know but yeah maintain
uh maintain a pretty decent hand
situation oh wait
no I'm good uh Mickey says what's your
favorite thing about being a dad is it
the freedom to say dad jokes without
impunity I mean I've been doing dad
jokes way before I was a dad uh but so
far the favorite thing I mean like these
kids when they smile at you it's like
man there's nothing better like and and
just like
that's it that's it if I can get the two
of them now especially because Justin
now six months like he's laughing now
like full-on laughing and he came out of
the womb smiling like this kid is a
freaking smile machine Luke was
definitely like a little slower to warm
up he's The Thinker it's very clear
Justin he's gonna win him on charm Luke
is the thinker but now he's smiling a
lot too and if I can get the two of them
in the morning that's where I'm I'm
really at my best with them and they're
at my they're at their best with me in
the morning so usually about like seven
to nine something like that that's when
I could really like focus in on them
like completely distraction free and
like when I have the two of them laying
there and I'm just like doing silly
things I'm like on the stomach and all
that stuff and they're just like
laughing hysterically and like yeah it's
just it's just great uh Michaela says
hey Dave I'm following your work for
about two months and I like your common
sense we need to come back to sanity I
agree a question how can we support each
other even more there should be a kind
of circle
I'm reaching out from Europe Austria to
be precise there's a lot going on here
too people waking up taking this in well
that's that's absolutely fantastic to
hear I don't know that we've ever
focused on Austria on this show in any
way whatsoever
um look this the thing the beauty of
doing these online shows
is that you are reaching people all over
the world right I mean I think probably
I don't know that I've I could think of
one maybe North Korea might be the only
country that I could think of off the
top of my head that that we've never
gotten fan mail from but I have had
yanmi park there and she's a North
Korean uh Refugee so that that counts as
something but the beauty of like this
this Mass political Awakening that's
happening in the United States and it's
happening all over the world because
whether we like it or not we are all
connected maybe we should be doing some
kind of like monthly like World recap or
something
I will talk to the team and welcome
aboard I'd appreciate your support uh
Tom says uh Dave let's put together a
locals Community member Cruise your
events are always so good it would be an
amazing combo of thoughts I would love
to do that you know we have a little bit
of international trip coming up at the
beginning of May which I'll fill you
guys in on shortly we are trying to pull
off do we have a rough idea for it like
a middle of March DC trip I don't want
to say the date exactly yet
okay it sounds like late March we are
going to do a locals DC trip it will be
only for locals community members we'll
do like a day in DC we'll all wander
around together I think Kevin McCarthy
is going to come give a talk we'll do
like a little uh little coffee situation
with him maybe we can get up to his
office take an Insider tour we're trying
to figure out more stuff like that you
know the thing is obviously with young
kids here my ability to Just Bounce
Around all over the place is is a little
bit tight at least in this first year
but a cruise I really like cruises you
know cruises are very controversial
people either love the cruise or they
hate the cruise there's nobody that has
like mixed feelings about the cruise
right
um I really enjoy the cruise like I've
also uh I enjoy casinos like I just like
I like a lot of that kind of like crazy
stimulation in a way
um so I would do I would do a cruise
situation but again you got to bear with
me on the timing and some of this uh
snow baby says there was a rumor Nancy
Pelosi bought a mansion in Florida what
if you woke up one day and found out
that she was your neighbor man so as far
as I know that that rumor fell through
it sounded like she was going to buy
like a 20 or 25 million dollar house of
course on the water I think in Jupiter
Florida and I guess it didn't happen I
can tell you this now I've never said
this on camera before but I was actually
working
on a sitcom pilot with Kirsty alley
um about basically she was going to sort
of play a Nancy Pelosi type moving to
Florida like a California Progressive
moving to Florida and then living next
door to a trump type and we had started
the beginning of the writing process and
then she got sick very very quickly out
of nowhere
um or as far as I knew it was out of
nowhere and she's no longer with us
unfortunately but maybe we could pick up
the idea the idea for the sitcom was
kind of kind of fun
um but uh yeah as far as I know Nancy
Pelosi does not live in Florida thank
God Ashley says what's your opinion on
inter-religious marriages my husband is
Jewish and I'm Catholic well I think as
long well first off as long as you're in
love that's the most important thing if
you love each other and you see the
world in a somewhat similar way and you
want to build something together that
will last possibly with kids and and
that that is
um
Eternal in a way uh I think that's
number one but I think on the second
part of that I mean I have many friends
that are intermarried one way or another
or this religion that religion or or
atheists and religious or all sorts of
stuff not many of those anymore actually
um but I think as long as you can
respect each other's traditions and
beliefs and you know as long as it
doesn't drive a wedge between you you
know what I mean like if you're if I
would say if you're the Catholic let's
say and you're constantly demanding that
the the Jewish person accepts Christ or
the Jewish person is constantly uh you
know demanding that the Catholic person
not accept Christ or something like that
like then you got a problem you got like
an existential problem with your
marriage and that's not going to work
but if you're raising a family and you
can bring them up with with two
traditions and explain this is what my
family and my ancestors believed this is
what my family and my ancestors believe
these are the foods we eat the cell the
holidays we celebrate how and why we do
all these things
um that seems pretty solid to me it
creates all sorts of complexities though
because there are things related to
marriages and what religions or the
child and are you confusing them to
surgery so it's not it's not easy for
sure I'm sure I don't have to tell you
that but I think there are definitely
ways to do it right uh Kathy says hey
Dave you're the best and thanks for all
the laughs I see climate emergency
masking lurking in the background what
is what say you yeah it's coming if you
don't think it's coming I'm sorry but
I've got a mask to sell you it's coming
they will lock people down again in blue
States and it will partly I don't know
if they're going to do it next because
of they're just going to release a new
covid or tell you that a new covet is
out there or it will be because of
monkey pox or it will literally because
be because of climate change my guess is
it's going to be climate change that
seems to be the direction that they're
pushing all of this in and they will say
you know it has finally happened here in
Los Angeles the smog is not lifting
right now it is not safe to breathe the
air you should wear masks and actually
it's best if you don't leave your house
at all we will send drones from Whole
Foods to your house and and keep your
windows closed and make sure you're
watching state-sponsored television you
gotta keep watching NBC to know what's
going on and they will just try to scare
the hell out of you and that sort of
does hearken back to that that question
about you know the state's uh separating
and all those things because I think one
thing is clear for sure regardless of
who's president during the next uh the
next pandemic or the next lockdown or
whatever you want to call it
there is going to be way more people and
way more states that will not fall in
line and thank God for that thank God I
live in one of those States and we
welcome all of you guys anyway more on
that DC trip coming up more on the
international trip coming up uh there is
no post game show today because I
actually pre-taped this because I'm in
Sarasota right now because as I
mentioned tomorrow Friday is the grand
opening of the rumble studio and offices
I will be live streaming from there
sometime early in the morning rumble.com
Reuben report or it'll be up on locals
reubenreport.locals.com I thank you very
much I will see you not well I'll see
you tomorrow just doing the rumble thing
be a little different than here but it's
me and you know we'll have fun okay see
ya
[Music]
in five jokes think about it think about
what you'd think about at the time
all right
here for Daryl and his band
that's an Applause line